so friend of mine this weekend she
sprayed some THC into her mouth and
apparently they found her on they called
911 went to the beach to you know kind
of get rid of it or whatever just kind
of hanging the Sun problem was she did
six sprays of THC and she passed out or
she just couldn't move and hi yeah but
by the time they found her she got so
[ __ ] burned that they called 9-1-1
and she's still in the hospital yeah so
she'd made his girlfriend she did it and
then stat outside in the Sun she well
she I guess she had they had been
partying all night as the story goes how
old is she she's 25 okay
they've been partying and then she but
but she didn't get much sleep
some was upcycled I'm gonna do some TV
so I can go to sleep goes walking on the
beach gets so high she sits down calmly
come by fall 12 yeah or no one she's
still out there not able to move skin
was a bubbling ah skin was a bubbling
white girl
yeah she's got darker skin but yeah
white lost the way but apparently
hospital dehydration sunstroke all kinds
of [ __ ]
I wouldn't blame that on the wheel well
the THC apparently was so strong it was
so strong that she couldn't it
incapacitated like she's I've been that
like sprays yeah but it was enough no
that's what I'm saying yeah yeah but you
never know how much is in there I was
probably the equivalent of you know who
the [ __ ] knows Jesus you're really that
high here been like hot so high that you
I couldn't cuz I was so high I couldn't
breathe I couldn't feel myself breathing
and I panicked
I've never been higher I didn't think I
was I couldn't breathe I'm in super
paranoid
yeah not at my age though well whatever
Rogan hasn't that weed sometimes one hit
had me done for a good six hours you get
to pick you okay come rescue me yeah I
had to leave my car at Rogan studio and
come rescue and pick you I ate a steak
and you're making
and for some reason it was taking
[ __ ] forever even the way you were
opening this package I was like he's
taking a lot I was secretly getting more
and more annoying I was like I'm just
sitting here and he's talking and he's
taking a long time to get that steak out
of the [ __ ] wrapper and then they
gonna do you had a whole system though
the way you make your steak use that
barbecue yeah man you know it didn't
have to pick your dumb ass up so you
know I was in the middle making dinner
yeah I just felt like I wasn't given the
proper welcome nah man you're high
always annoyed I was making dinner yeah
exactly you know that's like how you and
I are it's like I don't think the
airport might be so close oh no I'm not
driving I would never do that it would
take seven minutes but I'm like no I'm
never right real friends don't ask those
favors
don't ask me help me move the airport
get the [ __ ] out of my face that you're
a man do it on your own dude also do get
on you so don't give me please never
call me please never call me and tell me
I could be a better friend like because
I'm busy or something you know oh my god
please never deny be friends they just
found the way can't simply can't I don't
get it from Bret anymore yeah sorry
doing this right now yeah yeah yeah yeah
watch your tongue oh good what's gonna
happen what are you gonna do use some of
that boxing you've been doing
[Laughter]